you ready but I got to flip over my
shoes so they don't get rained on the
hailstones spend their summer along the
Kowalik River where they only have a
brief window to gather resources before
the freeze returns for chip and Agnes
teaching their daughters how to survive
in the Arctic is a priority and a valued
native tradition we can start with
soured ox
since the sour docks are ready what we
call sour docks in English they call
hogs in a new pack and their local green
that we like to eat with their little
salt is slightly on the sour side so
they're good with vinegar and oil a
little bit of salt and pepper and
they're a really good green and they're
really fresh and the time to pick them
is now well you can spot these red
stocks that are up and around them there
will be a nice succulent greens and
they're pretty tasty actually I like
them I grew up eating stuff but we
should go gather them you know on
riverbeds not much different this you
know got to make sure you pick the right
correct green so we don't get sick one
year we thought we picked all greens and
then there happen to be a few poisonous
flowers mixed in with those and I happen
to eat them and I got really sick and
after that when the girls started
watching every plant we pick and they
have it in their head if they don't pick
the correct path somebody's gonna get
sick so it's very important for the
girls to know what they need to look for
it's important for them to know where to
go to pick these things and how to
preserve them if they don't have this
experience and if they don't know what
flowers to eat they might go hungry
being out here there's no reason to go
hungry if you know what you're doing
really not scoring too high here are we
yeah we picked most of the big ones
already and there's just quite a few
smaller ones we should just go downriver
you guys want to go a couple miles yeah
we could probably they'll be bigger
leaves we're heading down to the coast
we've pretty much picked out this whole
little Valley here you don't ever want
to impact an area too heavy that it
wouldn't grow back we go for quality not
quantity so we're gonna go wherever it's
wet wherever you see Lakes wherever you
see rivers creeks things like that
that's where we'll be and that's where
the [ __ ] will be